I always say to people and life is found
in the dance between what you desire
most and what you fear most the worst
advice you can give somebody is what you
would do because they're not you there's
a number one skill of an entrepreneur is
people skills and leadership skills rise
and shine it's an espresso time what's
up believe nation it's Evan I believe in
you and this channel is designed to be a
part of your daily success routine so
let's start your day off right together
grab your coffee and sip on today's
message learn how to lead over you Tony
Robbins also if you want to know what
Tony and other successful entrepreneurs
have to say about building unstoppable
confidence check out my 250 for
confidence series where every day for
the next 254 days I will send you a
morning video for free to help you build
your confidence to link to join is in
the description below the fact that
human beings our strongest drive is the
need to stay consistent with how we
define ourselves so while you're in this
passionate state that's where you make
decisions so if you want to change your
life my friends you've got to change
your physiology and you got to change
your focus
I really believe Nordic influence people
you got to know what already influences
them who the mistake that we make is we
don't connect enough to figure out who
this person is and what most of us do is
try to lead other people by influencing
them the way we've the influence they
try to influence their kid to clean the
room the way that would make you do it
but even though they're your kid they're
different than you and so they're gonna
do it for a different set of reasons
than what you would do it for you might
have done it because someone told you to
but your kids I'm all day long that's
not it there has to be something else
it's a sense of freedom they get from it
or a sense of mass just something that's
going to move them so I always say there
are two things that influence everyone
if you want to be a leader you have to
know how to change other people's States
a person is in a no state a person's in
an angry state persons in a frustrated
state you have to be able to influence
their stake is if you change their state
you're going to change the result they
but the second thing you have to
understand is what are people's
blueprints blueprints my shorthand for
what are the values what do they believe
what do they fear I always say to people
that life is found in the dance between
what you desire most and what you fear
most if I want to lead you and support
you I got to know your goals your
desires I don't know what you're scared
about what you're fearful about what
stresses you out and if I understand
that I can communicate in a way that'll
inspire you to maximize not only when
I'm here that's management leadership is
on God and you've raised your own
standard and you're gonna continue to
perform at a higher level influencing
someone starts with you being their
chief goal officer that is your job
be their chief goal officer you have to
understand what their values are you
have to understand what their ambitions
are you have to sustain who they are
before you can influence them the worst
advice that you can give somebody this
is this is a challenge a lot of leaders
face when they're building organization
the worst advice you can give somebody
is what you would do the worst advice
you can give somebody is what you would
do because they're not you because they
have different values because they have
different ambitions because they want a
different path than what you've taken
and so if you just say here's what I
would do and then you come off and
feeling like you're a hero and a genius
you've made me screwed them over and so
you need to start by being a chief goal
officer if people are not listening to
you if people are not following your
orders that people do not respect you is
because you're giving them wrong advice
because you have not done the work to be
their chief goal officer and then help
them accomplish what they want to
accomplish and figure out the best path
for them okay so how do you become
somebody's chief goal officer I'm gonna
give you three ways to do it step number
one is know their one word in credo your
one word is your most important core
value the thing that you stand on and
the Credo are the three things that make
up that define what that one word is for
people when I first wrote the book your
one word I didn't anticipate it being a
leadership book I thought it'd be just
something that you use for yourself but
it's shocking how many people now buy
the book and give it to their team so
you get a window of what your team's
core values are so you know how to move
and inspire them as an example if
they're one word if somebody on your
team is one word is freedom then you
gives you a window of how to handle that
person they don't want to be
micromanaged they want to be told what
to do 24/7 they need to have some
freedom in
decision-making and controls so they can
go off and do their job so they can
express themselves so that they can have
fun and be happy the more you are
handcuffing them the more they feel like
you're putting them into jail the more
you're gonna lose and you're not gonna
influence them so step number one is
figure out for everyone on your team
what are their one words and credos step
number two is what are their ambitions
what do they want what do they want to
accomplish are they trying to make a lot
of money are they trying to move to
another country they try to learn some
certain skills like what do they want
what are they here for what do they try
to get because yes they're here to do a
job yes you want them to figure out how
to do XYZ because you have a business
target and you're trying to accomplish
that thing awesome they're a human being
they're not a robot they're not a monkey
they're not just typing things in for
you so you could accomplish your goals
you have your goals and they have their
own set of goals and if you are not
being their chief goal officer if you do
not understand what their ambitions are
then you're gonna lose then you're gonna
give them tasks that they don't want to
do anymore that they're gonna grow and
learn and want to expand and you don't
know how they want to expand and they're
gonna quit and they're gonna leave you
and y'all can go to push them forward
you have to do the job of figuring out
how if they want to go here this is
their ambition and they're here right
now you have to make that path visible
you have to show them how they can go
from here to here and then you put
everything that they're doing in that
light so this is the path I want you to
get here too I know you want to be here
I want you to get here here's how to get
there and they may not see it because
they haven't experienced it yet they may
not be able to tie the dots together to
say oh if I do this I'll be able to get
there that's your job help them be their
chief goal officer understand their
ambitions step number two and then step
number three is how can you run parallel
paths together so it's pretty unlikely
that somebody on your team will stay
with you forever they have ambitions
they have goals they want to get
somewhere and if you understand what
their goals are and you know where you
want to go then great you're running
this parallel path together and that
parallel path might be for three months
it might be for a year it might be for
six years or it might be forever but at
some point they want to go off and do
something else
you're a stepping stone for them to get
somewhere else and that's awesome you
should celebrate that don't fear that
celebrate that and then figure out how
you can be a part of their success how
you can run that parallel path together
and then when they're ready push
them away like you're ready you should
go off and do that thing now go do that
thing you're ready you shouldn't be with
me anymore figure out how you can run
the parallel paths together and then
help them go and be the person they want
to be
once they've hit the end of the road
with you so that's a three step process
to being somebody's chief goal officer
one figure out what their one word and
credo are to figure out what their
emissions are and then three figure out
how can you run parallel paths together
now I've got a really special bonus clip
for you that I think you're gonna enjoy
but before that question of the day I
want to know how are you gonna be a
better leader what is what is one thing
you took from this video that you're
gonna apply to your business to be a
better leader I would love to hear from
you please put it in the comments below
says how do you get the right people and
then how do you keep the right people
that's the most important part of
business you know that's why I went to
military school and I went to I was a
Marine Corps the reason I when I talk to
military veterans you probably have the
most important skill of all because all
we're trained to do whether you're the
general or a private you're taught to be
leaders it is a number one skill of an
entrepreneur is people skills and
leadership skills and unfortunately most
people don't have it coming into so when
I do my talks to veterans and all this
stuff I really want to encourage them
you know cuz they're pretty depressed
because they can't get it the other
they're a Walmart greeter which is a
good job but they're afraid to take the
leap into entrepreneurship so but
military guys I don't care what branch
of service just by the indoctrination
process and the survival rate where they
go to combat or not is that you learn
leadership skills people skills you've
got to have that you know whether
whether you're a team of one you still
have to deal your customers and the good
customers bad customers lawsuits taxes
government regulations and all this
they're all people skills you know so
when somebody says to me what do I need
to learn I said boy you'd better learn
how to communicate pretty quickly to
people you don't like and get them on
your side you know how to win friends
and influence people basic book the
number one skill of an entrepreneur is
people skills and I'm gonna get right
into the first rule which is leader lead
thyself so leadership is not just for
CEOs leadership is not just for prime
ministers and presidents and people with
large bank accounts and massive offices
leadership is not only an opportunity
but the responsibility of every man
woman and child on the planet today no
matter what it is you do whether you're
a filmmaker a startup entrepreneur a
manager of a corporation a bread creator
or whatever it's got a baker I guess
there'll be a baker whether you're a
teacher or whether you're a firefighter
whether you're a politician whether you
are a gardener whether you are a wall
maker I don't know whatever it is you do
but every day you walk out in the world
gives you not only that opportunity but
brings with it the awesome
responsibility to show up as a leader
because leadership really isn't a title
you know my book the leader I had no
title you've probably read it
leadership is less about a title and
it's more about an approach a way of
being and some of the traits of leaders
without titles the radiant optimists in
a world gone cynical one of the things
about leaders without titles they don't
see their job as a job they see their
job as a craft no matter what their work
is they understand there's dignity in
all labor one of the traits of leaders
without titles they are relentlessly
improving everything they touch so they
leave it better than they found it and
so the first rule for a monumental life
is simply leader lead thyself which just
means see yourself as a leader and don't
wait for the people around you to start
leading lead where you're planted lead
by example you stand up first be an army
of one when it comes to leadership and
spreading that leadership possibility
around you if you had to think of one
word that's most important to you or
that sums you Apple
that would be collect a little beacon if
you want more Tony and learn how to
train your mind and body like he does
check out the video right next to me I
think you'll enjoy it continue to
believe and I'll see you there
if you want to end suffering you have to
make the most important decision in life
which says I'm gonna live in a beautiful
state every day no matter what